dr david agus joins us now to unpack
some of the things we just heard in
ben's report first
david can you tell us what is a
protective glow that's number one number
two
the president says that he is immune and
that he can't get the virus
it's all it's been reported many many
times that you're not really immune
after this so can you set the record
straight
protective glow and are you immune
is he immune protect protective glo
i don't know i mean i guess that you
know it when you see it you know your
body has two ways of giving you immunity
making antibodies
and making t cells the antibody tests
that we have now look for the presence
of antibodies they don't look for
neutralizing anybody's to actually give
you immunity
so there is no antibody test for
immunity at the present time
and the t-cell test is very difficult to
do and there's no
uh talk that the president actually had
that done so we don't know he had
immunity
that treatment he got of monoclonal
antibody cocktail
did work uh uh real work for about three
to four weeks in terms of protecting an
individual we think from the virus
although again that hasn't been proven
in clinical trials so he probably has
some immunity
how long it will last i don't know but
it's very difficult to say
definitively i have immunity in fact the
lancet infectious disease is reporting
the first case of reinfection what does
that say to you
in this country well yeah there
there now there are many cases of
reinfection in the country this is a
very uh
well done molecularly documented case
that's published
but you know it's critical that immunity
lasts for a certain period of time and
we don't yet have a test
to know how long that is an individual
the hope is
is that a vaccine will last for years
when you have the virus we think you
have several months of protection in
general across the population some
people are shorter
some are longer but the hope is is much
longer with a vaccine
the other thing that's confusing david
for a lot of people is the president
is refusing to say that the president
has said that he's tested negative
the white house doctor is not saying
that the words he's using is
the president is no longer considered a
transmission
risk to others is there a distinction
between the two statements
you know as it was written as such one
assumes that
there may be a a positive test and
realize that after
coping 19 when you are not infectious
you can still test positive
because the test looks for about 30
letters or the 30 000 of the virus and
those are fragments
the test is detecting so it's very
difficult
to know if someone is infectious or not
with the current test
we still need better and more
appropriate testing in the country
all right dr david agus thank you for
your time this morning